si vous faites des entrevues ce n'est
pas pour exposer votre peine ou faire un
spectacle c'est vraiment pour dire il
faut que ça change
le contexte des locations de ces
bâtiments-là ça a pas de bon sens
c'est ce qui nous a renversé le plus
dans la famille lorsque nous avons
appris suite
au feu quand nous avons appris de la
façon dont ça c'est fait comment ça
c'est fait
les mesures de sécurité dont on apprend
de jours en jours qu'elle était
absolument sinon pas totalement légitime
du moins non conforme à ce qu'elle
devrait être pour opérer un bâtiment
patrimoine parce que votre petite fille
a appelé il n'a pas pu sortir et elle a
dit au 91 c'est ça qui est tragique elle
a dit une fin il y a pas de fenêtre je
peux pas sortir
c'est ça me donne des frissons juste un
en parler parce que
je l'imagine et tout ça c'est fait dans
un délai très court dans un intervalle
de 3 minutes il y a eu deux appels le
premier était fait par ma petite fille
Charlie et le deuxième par l'ami qui
accompagnait sur le même téléphone que
Charlie utilisait
et le deuxième téléphone était vraiment
de un appel de détresse venez nous
chercher on est incapable de sortir
on le souligne on aurait même pas besoin
de le souligner mais ce qui va à
l'encontre de toute norme du normes du
bâtiment quand on loue on le dit quand
il y a pas de fenêtre il y a pas de
chambre possible il y a pas
d'appartements possible c'est un
bâtiment qui est patrimonial donc on a
rapiécé des logements et il y en a selon
nos informations puis déjà vendredi on
en parlait il y en a au moins 7 ou 8 qui
était loué sur Airbnb en plus donc
qu'est-ce que ça vous dit ça sur la
réglementation qui est pas là
une ville et responsable
d'appliquer les règlements qu'elle
définit alors
si c'est 10 règlements-là sont pas
appliqués mais
on constate que seulement dans le vieux
Montréal il y a plus de 1000 logements
appartements qui sont sous la plateforme
d'Airbnb et ça c'est sans compter les
autres plateformes d'un lieu Montréal la
quantité
d'immeubles patrimoniaux de vieux
immeubles ça nous fait se poser des
normes questions comment si cet immeuble
a réussi à opérer à des conditions
négligence comme ceci imaginez-vous
ailleurs de Montréal commencer
vous avez peut-être entendu la mairesse
aujourd'hui dire c'est pas facile de les
prendre sur le fait oui c'est interdit
d'enview Montréal mais c'est pas facile
de prendre sur le fait Québec dit-elle
et responsable d'envoyer des inspecteurs
donc
qu'est-ce que ça vous qu'est-ce que ça
vous inspire quoi ces paroles là de la
classe politique aujourd'hui rien de
très réconfortant comment voyez-vous
être réconforté en tant que famille
des victimes qui qui ont été prises dans
le brasier
lorsque
j'oserais pas vous dire que c'est devenu
la coutume mais on s'envoie la balle la
ville prétend que faire ça déjà
le Québec nous notre responsabilité
pendant ce temps-là ça prend un feu de
cet ampleur des victimes qui ont rien
demandé
surtout à 18 ans surtout à 18 ans
belle jeune fille
intelligente allumée
toute la vie de réel
15 minutes
la police puis j'ai plus parler à votre
Fils au Père la police c'est pas un
réconfort parce que c'est un mot exagéré
dans les circonstances mélodie elle n'a
pas dû souffrir parce que là ils ont été
c'est la fumée que
évanoui là
où
ça ça pense un peu la plaie c'est
qu'effectivement ça s'est fait
rapidement et que l'intoxication de la
fumée n'a pas pris le temps alors
trois grands papas donc de Charlie
victime de l'incendie merci de nous
avoir parlé puis on répète vous voulez
que que ça serve que ce drame là au
moins servent à quelque chose merci de
nous avoir reçu si je peux juste me
permettre de remercier
le public tous les gens qui nous ont
donné un amour ou inconditionnel depuis
l'événement à la famille Lacroix et à la
famille laka
merci à vous tous merci de m'avoir reçu
c'est la moindre des choses merci
beaucoup